(upbeat electronic music)
- [Justine] Right now,
we are at Kualoa Ranch
and this is probably one
of my most favorite places,
I think, in the entire world.
It is the most beautiful ranch.
There's over 4,000 acres
and they have shot so many films here.
I'm pretty sure you guys
have seen so many of them.
We also did a really amazing
tour here back in October.
I never posted that vlog,
but today you're finally
gonna get to see it.
But first, we're gonna hop on this boat
and go to small, tiny cool island.
I have a lot of stuff!
(upbeat electronic music)
So guys, one thing that
I definitely recommend
you should never drone from a moving boat.
It's a really bad idea.
So thankfully, we're not moving.
I mean, it's definitely possible,
but I would not recommend it.
(upbeat electronic music)
So I'm about to attempt
a really fun drone shot.
I basically want to fly it
through this little boat
and up and away, so
let's hope that it works.
I'm gonna try two,
I'm gonna do one facing me
and then one facing away.
Fingers crossed, guys.
(drone whirs)
It looks so awesome!
(upbeat electronic music)
(bright electronic music)
They filmed Jurassic Park here!
They filmed so many movies,
and we're going to go
to all those locations and check them out.
So let's go, we've got
to go rally the troops.
We are here with our
family and our friend Susie
and I don't know where
Bree went, she's somewhere.
(bright electronic music)
- [Man] Alright, so he's
gonna be your tour guide.
- [Women] Hi.
- [Justine] I'm Justine, nice to meet you!
- [Tour Guide] Nice to meet you!
- [Justine] Alright,
everybody hop in! Get in!
(group yells excitedly)
- Can I sit in the front?
- [Tour Guide] You can.
- Okay! Yes!
Everyone have enough room?
- [Woman] Have everybody?
(everybody cheers)
Hello, wow! This is great!
(bright funky music)
So this is where Jurassic
World was filmed,
and the helicopter that
took off in the beginning
was actually right here,
but they dismantled it
because they didn't
want actual helicopters
to land here inside of the ranch.
The visitor's center was
brought in all by CGI,
so basically, this was a
canvas for them to start with.
And, the rest of it was
all filled in with CGI.
(bright funky music)
This is probably my favorite
part so far of the tour.
This is where the T-Rex
escaped at the beginning
of the movie.
And they said that normally on movie sets
they end up taking down all of the props
and things like that, but this
they left up because it was
a very highly requested thing
that people wanted to see on the tour.
This is so cool!
This is the lookout behind us.
We're gonna go up there
right now, but they said that
they're doing some
construction on the glass.
Because, all of this stuff
had to sort of be remade.
Because, originally, when
things are created for movies,
they're all tore down because
they're not built to last.
Especially, in Hawaii in
tropical conditions like this.
We're goin' up, look here it is!
Ah, this is so cool!
I'm freaking out guys, I'm so excited.
Look the iPad!
Not sure which gen this is?
Hmm, I don't think
they've updated to iOS 11.
And the Photo Booth app,
somebody definitely Googled
(laughs) iPad screen.
Next stop.
(slow ethereal music)
(moving electronic music)
Behind me is the restaurant
where they filmed
for 50 First Dates with Adam
Sandler and Drew Barrymore.
I've got some popcorn here.
It's snack time and break on the tour.
But, this is so pretty.
Like, isn't this awesome?
- So this right here is where
they docked the submarine in Lost.
- [Justine] Wow.
- [Man] Did you know that, John?
(Tour Guide sings)
- [Justine] This is such an awesome view!
(upbeat electronic music)
Right here is Hurley's
golf course from Lost,
if you guys remember that from the show.
Any Lost fans? God I love that show.
Those right there are
Godzilla's footsteps.
They're pretty huge.
Now that I'm up close to it,
it just kind looks like a big dirt hole.
You would never be able to
tell that this was a footstep.
Well, this is a pretty cool view.
(cheerful music)
This is from Kong: Skull Island,
I never saw the movie,
so I'm not really sure
what this is in reference to,
but now I'm gonna have to see it,
and then I'll be able to
be like wow, we were there.
(Justine laughs)
There should be a shrine nearby!
We're now heading into
the World War II bunkers,
which is also doubled
as some scenes for Lost.
(muffled chatter)
Hey! Awh here it is, the Lost, this is
what I was looking for! Yes!
This is unbelieva-
(group screams)
Awh, I hate you!
- [Man] Did we actually get you?
- You actually did, oh my god
I was really scared I'm crying!
- That was a genuine yell.
- [Justine] I was freaking scared,
oh my god, I hate you.
Anyway, now that I am not
as terrified as I was before.
- [Jenna] You yelled so loud.
(slow electronic music)
Guys, thank you so much
for watching this vlog,
that was basically, it seems like almost,
six months in the making.
I love this place, and if
you guys are ever in Oahu,
I definitely recommend,
you have to check it out
because it is just
incredibly breathtaking.
The views, the scenery,
and all of the people here
are so nice that it's such an experience,
and I hope that one day you
guys can also experience it too,
but now, that's it, that's
the end of the vlog!
I'll see you guys later.